[Music]
all right
welcome
the smartphone Awards 2022. it's one of
my favorite videos y'all knew it was
coming it's a bit of a tradition around
here to revisit the smartphones that
came out during the calendar year 2022
and then I like to uh recognize and
reward some of the best and some of the
worst that came out and some of the
interesting stuff that happened during
this calendar year there's a lot usually
we forget about a lot of this stuff but
this is one of my favorite videos to
make we even have of course no spoilers
but we've got some trophies for the
winners as well they're super nice so
from flagships to mid-rangers to budget
phones to Specialty phones to folding
phones I got to use them all I got I
have my own opinions about them and you
know some of you may agree with some of
these Awards some of you may disagree
but one thing is for sure is they're my
Awards so without any further Ado let's
start giving them out so the first
category is best big phone now I mean
look at this table obviously these
phones have gotten bigger and bigger
over time to the point where pretty much
every phone is big but I still like to
reward a phone
had a great use of that space because
you still want a big screen but also a
big battery maybe big speakers some nice
cameras and the whole thing just being a
good use of all that extra space and so
my winner for the best big phone of the
Year actually came out right near the
beginning of it and that is Samsung's
Galaxy s22 Ultra so Hardware wise I feel
like this one just pretty much did it
all here it's got the big 6.8 inch
display one of the absolute best in the
business it added a stylus but still
included a 5 000 milliamp hour battery
which is the same as the year before
multiple great cameras on the back a
pair of great telephotos good speakers
good software really no Hardware flaws
to speak of to the point where maybe
you'd say was kind of boring which I
think is actually a good thing if you're
looking to spend this much on a phone
you don't want anything to be too weird
about it and so yeah this one's the
category in a way that I think the notes
usually did in the past so it's sort of
a return of the note but I do also give
some runner-ups and honorable mentions
in some of these categories too and
that's what I'm going to do in best big
phone which means the runner-up is the
Asus Rog phone 6. really similar
actually in a lot of ways to Samsung's
flagships just missing a couple little
things it's a little more specialized no
wireless charging but it's got a screen
on the back and it's much more gaming
Centric but I gotta shout it out for the
incredible massive stereo front-facing
speakers and also the headphone jack
big phone
should have room for a headphone jack
and also a little shout out a little
humble mentioned to the xiaomi mix fold
2. this it didn't have an IP rating it
wasn't quite you know available for
everyone worldwide but this is one of
those folding phones where it folded
just to about the same thickness as a
normal phone which is sort of like one
of those breakthrough moments in folding
phones I think and now we can start to
feel like they're on their way towards
being usable big phone
smaller package all right next category
best small phone so now we're on the
other end of the spectrum right there
are not a lot of small phones and this
is a rare category and I'll be honest
this one wasn't close so last year's
winner as you might recall was the
iPhone Mini they killed that this year
so that wasn't even going to qualify so
what would be the best small phone of
the year
it's the best small phone I've ever seen
and that is Asus Zenfone 9. this phone
is so nice and they made a lot of great
decisions across the board here so small
it's relative but it's a 5.9 inch
display relatively compact Flagship
specs Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 a 1080p
High refresh rate OLED great software
tons of ram really fast and a
surprisingly great camera and if this
phone this small can have a headphone
jack then what's everybody else's excuse
right uh there are a lot of great things
I liked about it it did have a couple
weird flaws like this weird soft touch
back that ended up discoloring a lot I
talked about that in the main review but
like man I was very surprised by the
battery life on this phone there's not a
lot of things that you're genuinely
surprised about in the smartphone world
now but a phone this small having such a
great battery life this is easily easy
best smartphone in this size but I will
give a little honorable mention a little
runner-up though because there was a
certain phone that came out right at the
very end of the year you guys might have
wondered why this video was so late I'll
give partial credit to this one Oppo
Find N2 this is that little passport
size phone it's got these flat edges and
it's still a folding phone which has got
a pretty solid display on the inside I
haven't done a full review about it yet
but it feels like this is a bit of a
preview to what a folding pixel might
look like which is really interesting
but all right let's get to the next
category which is best camera
or should I say best camera system
across the board because there's a lot
to a good camera from photo quality to
video quality but also speed of capture
and auto focus reliability and ease of
use and file formats and all this other
stuff so we did something really
interesting this year we did a blind
smartphone camera test in the form of a
website that we built where we gave
everyone the ability to vote on whatever
photos they like in three different
categories and we had 16 different
phones from the year all competing
against each other and the overall
winner across all three categories was
the pixel 6A incredibly and actually
runner-up to it was the pixel 7. so
these are clearly some really good photo
quality phones but I'm not giving them
the trophy for best camera system I'm
also not giving it to the Vivo x80 Pro
Plus or X90 Pro Plus which were low
light Kings they had a really great
combination of software and a really
impressive sensor the hardware stack is
great but no my winner for best overall
camera system in 2022 is going to the
iPhone 14 Pros so this has now become
the longest defending champion of a
single category ever this is the fourth
year in a row the iPhone has taken down
the camera category because again it's
great across the board so image quality
as we know is solid right we knew that
but the time to open the camera to
actually snap a photo is extremely quick
the autofocus is fast I'd say you could
fairly give the pro iPhones like an A
minus to a B plus for photos but then in
the video Department it's a whole
different dimension and it's not really
even close I've been running the
autofocus YouTube channel now for a
couple months doing a lot of videos on
cars shot entirely on smartphones and
you can tell the difference when I shot
a video on the iPhone's camera versus
the other smartphone cameras it's how
good it looks it's the audio quality
it's the consistency of color it's the
prores the sharpness I'm much first
shooting videos on iPhones and I think
I'm not alone there and I'll say it
still takes a long time to get the files
off of the iPhone and I hope they fix
that but it's the winner for best camera
system okay so next up let's do battery
this is the best battery overall
um I I think this is one of the more
objective categories probably but it's
it's including a little more obviously
than just the battery size I want to
include just the battery experience how
long it takes to charge how long it
lasts on a charge battery flexibility
features and things like that how long
the battery health does and so my winner
for best battery in a 2022 phone
it is a defending champ it is the Asus
Rog phone six this one has not a 4 000
not a 5000 but a 6 000 milliamp hour
battery it's got 65 watt fast charging
so you can go from zero to full and
under an hour and on top of that there
is a bevy of battery management features
so obviously you can turn the 165hz
display down all the way to six years if
you want to and get a ton of battery but
then there's also like charge limit
features pass-through charging things
like that this phone
is a king as far as battery life
experience and it actually charges fast
probably the only knock against it is
that it doesn't have wireless charging
which most other phones in its price
range do have but as far as just worry
free battery that's the winner and I
will give a runner-up in this category
to the iPhone 14 plus so a lot of us
kind of saw this coming when Apple
killed the mini iPhone in favor of a
plus sized iPhone that doesn't have the
promotion OLED display so this is a big
simple 60hz display that is uh just
powered by a massive battery in the
iPhone massive for an iPhone and so with
wireless charging and with all the other
things that Apple does to prevent
batteries from having problems I'd say
that's a pretty great battery experience
and I'll also give a quick shout out an
honorable mention because the Asus
Zenfone 9. I got it I keep coming back
to this the way it surprised me with
battery life this is a 4300 milliamp
hour battery in this phone it also
doesn't have wireless charging the
charging speed is decent but I was
genuinely shocked by how well this phone
held up on battery it's who would have
thought that a phone's small like this
would have one of the best batteries of
any phone that came out during the
calendar year but anyway okay next up is
the design award
I feel like this is the hardest one
every year to think of or to give out
just because it's it is the most
subjective now this is uh it's actually
changed over the years it used to be I
think I called it best build quality or
just best overall build or materials or
industrial design but it's eventually
just evolved into like
who can step outside of the box and do
things a little different design wise
because that honestly does not happen
very much in smartphones these days and
sometimes it kind of feels like a
process of elimination like oh I can't
give this to a phone that played it too
safe right lots of phones look basically
the same as last year I definitely can't
give it to a phone that made like an
obvious regression from the year before
or has like a glaring issue with build
or materials or failed generate
everything's test or something I can't
give it to an iPhone either can I I mean
they still have the biggest Notch but oh
there's the dynamic Island though too
maybe
the the design award for 2022 is gonna
go
to the nothing phone
the nothing phone one
get it
the design I think is literally the best
thing about this phone maybe second best
so it's got this sort of transparent
look which is definitely trying
something new and then the glyph
interface with these lights on the back
they light up for notifications they can
also light up as a fill flash for video
if you want it also is a wireless
charging indicator on the back it
definitely skirts the line right between
gimmick and feature like a lot of people
will get this phone and have fun with it
for a week and then never use it again
but I find it really neat I think it's
cool that you can see how much battery
is as you're charging I don't know
little things like that you don't see a
lot of phones trying new stuff the rest
of the phone happens to be pretty good
too so I have no problem giving the
nothing phone the design award for 2022
and then I do also want to give an
honorable mention in design to that
xiaomi mix fold 2. there were a number
of folding phones that came out during
this year but as I mentioned earlier
this is the first one that sort of
passed that barrier of actually being
the same thickness as a normal phone I
mean look at this is another phone that
came out during this year it's it's very
close in overall thickness so a lot of
phones you pick up like this is
Samsung's folding it just feels it's
thicker than a normal phone and you
think about that all the time when
you're using it so I wanted to reward
this one for actually getting to that
point where now there's other things to
fix still about folding phones but this
feels very usable and pocketable and
gives you the benefits of unfolding to a
huge screen shout out to xiaomi all
right let's give out a value award I
like this one this is uh this is
actually pretty close as well this year
too notice it's uh it's one of the more
controversial Awards it used to be best
budget phone but budget means something
different for everyone so I'm just
calling this like best bang for the buck
you can kind of picture the Pyramid of
phones and when you see a good one you
know what I'm talking about when you see
a phone that has a great price I'm going
by launch price MSRP so the winner I'm
giving my winning by a little bit best
value award to the pixel 7. this phone
came out at 5.99 and it's one of the
best 599 phones I've ever seen I mean
it's pretty clear it's the whole Google
Flagship experience it's also got the
tensor chip Flagship same as a more
expensive one it's also got the same
main sensor the same Flagship cameras
the more expensive one it has a great 90
Hertz OLED flat display it's so good
that it made the 7 Pro kind of feel like
not that good of a deal because 5.99
there's not a lot that you can get for
this price that does this well in fact
I'd argue nothing so this is one of my
favorite phones that came out this year
but it just barely beats out another one
of my favorite phones that came out this
year which is Asus Zenfone 9 really
unique combo for this one which launched
at 6.99 it also now has the Snapdragon 8
plus gen one it's got a ton of ram 120
hertz display a flat OLED again but also
like the fingerprint reader on the side
a headphone jack an incredible battery
life I mean these two phones could go
back and forth head to head I could
easily be swayed here but those two were
awesome to see that's probably the best
6.99 phone I've ever seen and among the
Myriad of other really good sub 400
phones that came out I want to give an
honorable mention to the real me 10 Pro
Plus this had a big 6.7 inch display you
can see the cameras on the back 5 000
milliamp hour battery but this camera
performs surprisingly well to a lot of
people it ended up beating thousand
dollar phones and it was second place in
votes per dollar in our blind smartphone
camera test really good overall package
for about 350 bucks I like the way this
launched and I think if you can get over
the way it shines it's a really good one
all right bust of the year
you know we give it out every year you
don't you don't like giving it out but
it's the one you hate to have to give
you know there's a lot of phones that
played it really safe which is
interesting and you could you could
argue for a lot of boring phones to just
have been too boring bust of the Year I
wish they did something more exciting or
interesting but I don't know a lot of
phones these days are very similar to
their previous years and I won't
penalize them for that if the previous
phone was good I really only had one
pick for bust of the year
and that's uh the OnePlus 10t
not a whole ton to say here uh it wins
this award for having a pretty big Delta
between expectations and possibilities
versus actual result not all of that is
oneplus's fault but I mean they've been
on this slight downward trend of value
and reputation and software experience
and cameras and a whole bunch of other
things like that there's not a whole lot
to like and also just feels like the
identity has sort of been eroded very
quickly over time we just had the the
Hasselblad thing added to the previous
OnePlus flagship phone and then the 10t
comes out and they don't even bother
with it I don't know if they're saving
it for the pro phones but it's like what
do you what is this what do you even say
about OnePlus phones anymore there's no
you can't even describe a OnePlus phone
without feeling really generic
so anyway yeah congrats on your award
bust of the year so that brings us to
the MVP the most valuable phone nah it's
not the valuable word it's the it's my
favorites list that's kind of what this
has turned into like the best overall
phone
combined with the best overall
experience the the best impact on the
industry there's a bunch of different
things that can float you to the top of
my favorites list from the smartphones
that came out this year and there are a
lot of really good ones you just heard
about great cameras great big phones
great battery lives Great Value some
surprises this was a really close one
for me really tough again
I could be swayed I don't even want to
say that about the MVP but I really
think it's that close I have two MVPs
okay but I'm giving my top dog my number
one MVP award for 2022.
to the pixel 7. this phone it deserves
it for sure like you heard about in its
previous win Great Value okay incredible
cameras great display Flagship software
experience really good battery life not
a whole lot missing and that's kind of
what you get with a phone like this
which is like all right the 7 Pro came
out for 300 more dollars and that's
actually a phone that I've used a lot to
this day but what do you really get more
for that the telephoto camera the extra
30 Hertz on the display like this phone
is such a good deal that it's it's hard
to recommend the 7 Pro I love
recommending the seven it's just an
overall excellent phone and I'm glad
that Google found their groove because I
actually just forgot
I haven't given out the most improved
award yet either
and that's also the pixel 7. Google
really found their groove with this
phone and to be fair there are a lot of
people who might criticize the design
they don't like you know the visor as
much I kind of like the glass visor of
the six a little bit more to be
perfectly honest but I actually like
that it's Unique if you look at a phone
from far away you know exactly what a
pixel phone looks like from across the
street you know what a pixel looks like
right they're doing this advertising
thing they're actually getting into
people's hands I just said my assistant
battle and like the assistant that runs
on this phone especially on the pixel is
excellent the voice recorder app all the
smart features hold for me the screen
call feature I just I can't say enough
good things pixel 7 great package
overall love this phone
so why am I so torn what is the other
phone that is such a good year that I
have a hard time only picking one MVP
what's the Zenfone 9 baby this phone
this had a lot of good things going for
it and it was one of my favorite phones
one of my biggest surprises of the Year
where do I start the design I really
liked despite not having the best wear
and tear experience I'm not a big case
person so I got to give it a knock for
that no wireless charging but the
Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 had amazing
performance this phone's battery life
was incredible it didn't charge fast but
like I was just amazed by that it has a
headphone jack it has the fingerprint
reader on the side which was very fast
but also had gestures and surprisingly
good cameras I mean these things ended
up top five top four maybe top three in
our blind smartphone camera test voted
by the masses so Asus has had great
cameras for years
just really liked this phone it's more
expensive it was 6.99 on launch I think
they did this weird thing in the US
where it launched for more but like if
you can get your hands on this phone and
pop a SIM card tray in it and it
actually will work well with your
carrier Zenfone 9 was a very close
second for my MVP for 2022. but then one
more I want to give an honorable mention
to the old boring Galaxy s22 Ultra it's
an expensive phone it has all the
hardware features didn't really do
anything wrong it just happens to have
one of the biggest batteries and the
best display in the business and one of
the best camera Suites in the business
and one of the best processors I mean
it's a boring really solid overall phone
and that's why it won best big phone and
so I'll give it that honorable mention
because a lot of us want to see that
just the best overall phone of the Year
highlighted and specs wise and what it
does for people I think that's a really
good phone to pick
of course right alongside the Rog phone
I could go on lots of great phones came
out this year but that's been it for the
smartphone Awards of 2022 feel free to
leave all the notes in the comment
sections below I know all of you guys
will have thoughts on this as we do
every year we'll talk about it but of
course if you're a company seeing this
and you want your trophy let me know hit
me up on Twitter or something I'll
literally ship it out to you I've done
that before okay that's been it
thanks for watching
Alicia Keys says she liked my jacket one
time all right see you later peace
[Music]